our 8 news now investigation into the
California Water hogs in a few places
they have been recycling water even
Wastewater for decades but in most
places it hasn't really caught on a new
sound investigator Kyle Payne went to
California to find out why he joins us
live in studio now with more Kyle Brian
here in southern Nevada they say every
drop of water that gets that hits a
drain pipe gets recycled in Los Angeles
that number is only two percent but
California they have more recycling
options storm water sea water and yes
sewage water the question is are they
recycling it or wasting it
what these seagulls and Ducks here in
South L.A probably don't know is the
water on which they Frolic and above
which they fly fills this man-made lake
in a park dedicated by a living legend
struggle for our community and Magic
Johnson Park named after the legendary
LA Laker has a pretty interesting Lake
of its own right here alongside the
playgrounds and walking trails the
scientists and Engineers are using this
intricate Maze of machines to treat and
reuse storm water and there's a lot more
to it than you might think and then the
water gets diverted here where it gets
treated with ozone Alum and
um chlorine what this all means is
they're trapping storm water that would
otherwise be unused and reuse it to
water the park
freeing up other Water Supplies like
that precious Colorado River water for
angelinos to drink and shower with while
the park Waters itself we often say
water is life and like life water supply
is short in Southern California not to
mention Southern Nevada and up against
questions about whether cities like LA
are doing enough to recycle water LA
Public Works principal engineer Matt
frary says La County's safe clean water
program cleverly known as prop W uses
280 million dollars costing the average
homeowner another 80 bucks a year to
fund hundreds of projects like this one
and increase the local water supply
little by little compared to the
millions and millions of gallons of
storm water that rush out to sea seems
like a pittance
a a single Park might seem like a
pittance but it's a step in the right
direction inevitably the direction of
the water recycling conversation leads
somewhere some Californians aren't quite
ready for and that's the idea of taking
Wastewater treated to high quality
standards safe enough for the public
Jesus Gonzalez is the manager of
recycled water policy for LA's
Department of Water and Power where
there are four wastewater treatment
plants serving some big commercial
customers about 4 billion gallons of
water a year and their 20 to 30 year
plans indicate that number should be
considerably higher so we can agree
there's a long way to go
long way to go we've made good progress
the conversation about water recycling
has landed at the doorstep of many a
courthouse where legal battles have
waged on for years but what's going on
here at the Santa Monica Courthouse has
nothing to do with the law it's got
everything to do with What Lies Beneath
that's kind of the mo of our industry is
out of sight out of mind out of sight
definitely hidden here underneath this
parking lot in downtown Santa Monica
where this first of its kind 96 million
dollar recycling plant leverages all
sorts of water including Municipal
Wastewater to make a drought resilient
Supply hoping to rely on their own
recycled water and not Colorado River
water but when it comes to recycled
Wastewater there's always the so-called
toilet to tap
the ick Factor ick factor it's gone away
gone away towards supplementing Mother
Nature with technology Wang says that
and millions of gallons of recycled
water every day in the grand scheme of
the massive drought along the Colorado
River though a million gallons is barely
a drop in the proverbial bucket you look
at that as a small drop in the bucket
but if everybody does wine you keep
adding that one up it becomes a much
larger number to help somebody water has
value even if it's Wastewater bill
hazenkamp is the manager of Colorado
River resources for the Metropolitan
water district which provides water to
19 million Southern Californians he says
Southern nevadans who Pride themselves
on recycling almost 100 percent of their
Wastewater have a leg up on California
because once sewer water or storm water
makes it to the Pacific Ocean it's gone
for good unlike Las Vegas where the
Wastewater flows back into Lake Mead
it's automatically recycled recycled
automatically or otherwise hazenkamp
says using the water twice or even three
times is necessary because the law water
situation is dire with Lake Powell and
Lake Mead at their lowest levels ever
that's bad it's really bad this is an
overwhelming
Endeavor it's an overwhelming Endeavor
it's an Endeavor the engineers at La
water and power are trying to solve
spending billions of dollars over the
next 10 to 20 years on small projects
like Magic Johnson Park and other much
larger projects along the same lines but
it's not easy do you think in our
lifetimes we'll see this water problem
solved
the mwd did tell eight news now they're
in the early stages of working on the
largest single water recycling project
in the country we'll follow the progress
of that and report back Kyle you told us
earlier that only two percent of the
water supply in Los Angeles is recycled
maybe people didn't hear that right just
two percent how is that even possible I
don't know but I double and triple
checked and desalination taking the salt
out of the seawater which is tomorrow's
story they're not even a factor in that
story La it's zero percent wow
Thursday
and see all of Kyle's special reports on
our website at 8newsnow.com and also be
sure to join us for part three tomorrow
night at 6 and 11.